sehr geehrte damen und herren die
gesundheitsminister von bund und länder
haben empfohlen auf das ende der
urlaubszeit zu reagieren und das regime
bei der einreise mit blick auf testung
und quarantäne anzupassen
die gründe hierfür möchte ich gerne
erläutern
in einer zeit mit diesen niedrigen
infektionsraten hier in deutschland war
und ist es wichtig zu verhindern dass
das virus durch reiserückkehrer wieder
stärker ins land getragen wird
wir mussten deshalb das test reben
lageabhängig an diese situation anpassen
bemerkenswert war im übrigen auch dass
wir sehen mussten dass länder die mit
großem aufwand und zum teil ja noch
härteren maßnahmen als hier in
deutschland wie in spanien innerhalb
weniger wochen die infektionszahlen
wieder sehr stark gestiegen sind es eine
dynamik bekommen hat so dass etwa ein
land wie spanien heute das land ist mit
den höchsten infektionszahlen in ganz
europa bezogen auf die bevölkerung und
das zeigt eben wie schnell ist wieder in
gleiten kann auch wenn das virus unter
kontrolle war
und es ist eben auch in ländern wieder
entglitten die beliebte reiseziele der
deutschen sind in diesem sommer und in
jedem sommer und deswegen war es
notwendig im juli eben auch zusätzliche
testung möglich zu machen das war im
übrigen auch erfolgreich es ist sehr
umfangreich getestet worden die tests
zahlen pro woche haben sich verdoppelt
von 4 500 1000 tests wie wir sie
regelhaft über viele wochen hatten zu
weit über 900.000 tests in der letzten
woche wir sehen auch dass insbesondere
bei der einreise aus bestimmten regionen
west balkan zum beispiel türkei wir
erhöhte im vergleich zu ansonsten dem
test geschehen erhöhten infektionszahlen
sehen und deswegen ist in richtig ist
dieses test angebot zu machen was wir im
übrigen auch sehen ist dass das
durchschnittsalter der infizierten im
wöchentlichen schnitt weiter gesunken
ist auf mittlerweile 32 jahre
das zeigt eben auch das ist vor allem
jüngere sind die im moment sich
infizieren
wir sehen bei den reiserückkehrern zwei
gruppen
in diesem sommer auch wenn wir auf die
altersverteilung schauen das eine sind
die jüngeren eher die um die 20 jährigen
wo es kroatien schwarzmeer eben auch um
manche party im urlaub gehen mag
und wir sehen dass es auch
verwandtschaft besucher sind familien
verbünde von kleineren kindern mit ihren
30 40 jährigen eltern die eben
zurückkehren er vom
verwandtschaftsbeziehung und deswegen
ist es wichtig in dieser sommerzeit
genau darauf auch die testangebote und
die testpflicht ausgerichtet zu haben um
eben infektion und einfach ins land
erkennen zu können übrigens um die
reisenden selbst zu schützen und ihnen
sicherheit zu geben aber im auch um alle
anderen bürgerinnen und bürger hier in
deutschland und das direkte umfeld der
betroffenen zu schützen